I don't know your dating history you
filthy flea it's not that
bad but I for one have always been in
long-term relationships and you know
what always happens after the one-year
mark
damn it Ana P close the damn door just
kidding I do that a weekend on top of
that I always start to turn into Tiger
girlfriend you need to start taking
multivitamins I think you need to start
drinking more water and if there's
anything I've learned from being a
serial monogamist
it's that relationships are hard a
work sometimes something
as simple as communication can become
difficult
what love you if there's anything I've
learned it's that relationships are just
a fancy smancy romantic word for
compromise to enough sex tonight
can I get a backrub after five minutes
ten seven done what's surprising is that
every single cutaway in this video is
actually based on my relationship
especially do that that happens way more
than it should this is the first
relationship I've been in where I've
actually lived with someone you know
what I love it more than I thought I
could I used to love playing house as a
kid and I loved it even more and now
that I'm an adult you want someone to
come home to and someone to share your
day with and someone who's gonna be
there for you no matter what and vice
versa
and you want a best friend that you can
have sex with whatever you want don't
get me wrong relationships take a lot of
work a lot of work but as long as you
with the right person
they're absolutely worth it yeah okay
bye give me a kiss give me a kiss give
me a kiss
hold on I get kisses welcome to raisins
Jesus